Trascrizione: camilla bisesti
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Noi siamo quello che mangiamo:
la mia storia inizia da qui.
Sette anni fa ho avuto
una brutta esperienza di salute,
che mi ha portato a dover cambiare vita,
e chiaramente rimettermi
completamente in discussione.
Quando, da un momento all'altro,
ti cambiano completamente le prospettive
e nel momento in cui riesci a recuperarle
non puoi fare altro che concentrarti
su quanto hai di più caro,
ed avendo tre figli
non ho potuto fare nient'altro
che concentrarmi sul futuro
dei miei figli, e delle nuove generazioni.
Ho avuto la fortuna di entrare in contatto
con il fenomeno del Vertical Farming
agli albori del Vertical Farming,
che è successo in Giappone,
a seguito del disastro di Fukushima,
momento durante il quale
hanno dovuto trovare
delle soluzioni concrete, reali,
per produrre del cibo
in maniera efficiente, sostenibile.
Ci sono quattro grandi sfide globali
intorno ai temi dell'alimentazione
e della nutrizione:
primo fra tutti, il cibo per tutti,
ovvero l'accessibilità al cibo.
Sappiamo benissimo tutti che, a oggi,
ci sono tantissime persone
che non hanno accesso al cibo.
Secondo, produrre cibo in maniera
sostenibile ed efficiente.
Terzo, cibo come elemento di benessere.
Finalmente ci siamo resi conto
che mangiando bene si può vivere meglio.
E quarto, cibo come elemento di cultura,
perché fa parte del bagaglio culturale
di tutti noi, che dobbiamo preservare.
Ma -
Qual è la situazione
da cui stiamo partendo?
Prima abbiamo avuto diversi scorci,
ma ve la cerco di riassumere.
Nel 2050, sono previste
quasi nove, dieci miliardi di persone,
di cui il 68 percento allocato
nei pressi dei grandi centri urbani.
Questo significa
che la produzione agricola
dovrà crescere di oltre il 70 percento,
rispetto all'attuale.
In altre parole,
nei prossimi 30 anni
dovremmo essere capaci
di produrre più cibo
di quanto non sia mai stato prodotto
negli ultimi 10.000 anni.
Ma allo stesso tempo,
ci sono dei fatti concreti:
un terzo di tutto il cibo
prodotto globalmente viene buttato;
e il 70 percento, pensate,
del consumo idrico mondiale
viene utilizzato dal comparto agricolo.
Ecco, questa è la situazione.
Bisogna trovare delle soluzioni concrete.
Noi riteniamo che il Vertical Farming
possa rappresentare una di queste.
Perché in molti casi la tecnologia priva,
ma in questo caso ridà.
In che modo?
Riducendo drasticamente la filiera.
Pensate che all'interno
di uno stabilimento di Vertical Farming
entra un seme
ed esce un prodotto confezionato;
e addirittura, nel nostro
caso specifico,
il nostro prodotto non va lavato
per essere mangiato.
Utilizzando in modo molto responsabile
le risorse naturali, quali suolo e acqua,
riusciamo a essere
fino a 300 volte più efficienti
dell'agricoltura tradizionale.
E risparmiando il 95-98 percento
di acqua in meno,
quello che vi so dire
è che l'unica acqua
che realmente consumiamo
è quella presente all'interno
della foglia d'insalata, pensate.
Ridando biodiversità,
geodiversità dentro e fuori.
Dentro perché, pensate,
è possibile ogni giorno produrre
prodotti diversi, ortaggi diversi,
quindi ribilanciare la dieta,
la dieta mediterranea.
Partiamo da un seme,
che è l'opposto di quello
dell'agricoltura tradizionale,
che è andata alla ricerca
di quello che è il super seme,
ovvero quel seme
che permetta agli agricoltori
di avere quel di più,
e che resista meglio
all'incostanza climatica
che stiamo vivendo.
Noi invece cerchiamo i semi vecchi,
quelli antichi e deboli,
quelli che nessuno può usare ma che,
proteggendoli strutturalmente,
è un'esplosione di gusto e di sapori.
E ridiamo, come dicevo prima,
biodiversità fuori.
Perché?
Perché riuscire ad avere
un'impronta completamente diversa,
rispetto all'agricoltura tradizionale,
significa ridare, risparmiare terreni
che possono essere riutilizzati
per ribilanciare un ecosistema
che oramai, abbiamo visto,
necessita realmente di un aiuto.
È una produzione in assenza totale
di chimica, di pesticidi, di erbicidi.
Un prodotto buono, sano e fresco,
365 giorni all'anno.
Non possiamo fermarci,
come dicevamo prima,
ad aspettare che qualcun altro
lo faccia per noi.
Noi pensiamo di essere
sulla giusta strada,
e alcuni dati ce lo dicono.
Pensate che negli ultimi
due mesi, nel mondo
sono state costituite più di 40 società
di Vertical Farming.
Questo non significa assolutamente
che sia una tecnologia semplice,
che sia un mondo facile,
ma questo significa
che è partito un movimento.
Un movimento che vuole dire basta,
che deve cambiare.
Ecco, noi l'abbiamo fatto.
In che modo? Cambiando prospettiva,
cambiando prospettiva
da orizzontale a verticale,
ed è sempre stato il modo utilizzato
nella storia dell'evoluzione.
Come siamo riusciti a farlo noi -
e io sono partito da solo
e oggi ho una famiglia bellissima
di oltre 65 persone
che lavorano insieme a me
e contribuiscono, e credono fortemente
in quello che facciamo.
Ecco: penso che ognuno di voi possa farlo,
ma bisogna avere il coraggio reale
di saper dire: "I don't care,
non mi interessa".
Cioè, nel momento in cui
tu vuoi realmente innovare,
ti troverai sempre
tantissime persone che ti diranno:
"No, non è possibile; no, questo no;
il prodotto va venduto così;
non fare quello; questo non è possibile!"
Vuol dire che stiamo facendo bene.
Il fatto che sia successo
in Italia, secondo me,
mi collega a quello
che ha detto il sindaco prima.
È vero, abbiamo un capitale umano
incredibile, in Italia.
Abbiamo delle persone
abituate a barcamenarsi
e a guardare avanti, ecco.
Noi l'abbiamo fatto, e io spero
che anche voi vogliate contribuire
a questo nuovo movimento.
Grazie a tutti.
(Applausi)